antoine claireaux en train de vouloir
alors cette réunion a permis de hockey
les affaires européennes n'est pas
uniquement
oui tout à fait le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères tout compte tout
comme son hôte du jour
ce sont tous les deux félicités de la
réintégration des parlementaires russes
au sein du conseil de l'europe après
cinq années d'absence à ce titre sergueï
lavrov a rappelé tout l'intérêt que la
russie porte pour les travaux de cette
institution européenne en particulier en
matière de sécurité et de stabilité sur
le continent européen
mais quand les journalistes ont pu poser
leurs questions on en est rapidement
arrivé à la situation dans le haut
karabagh et en particulier la question
du non respect du cessez-le-feu roggo
regarder je pense qu'aujourd'hui le plus
important et je pense pas que ça demande
un gros effort c'est d'arrêter toute
forme de confrontation temps entre les
parties que au niveau des responsables
des acteurs responsables au niveau
international je pense pas que sa
demande de grands efforts ici il faut un
système de contrôle de respect du
cessez-le-feu nous travaillons
activement notamment avec le ministère
de la défense et avec nos collègues
d'ag2r badjan et d'armes est lié et nous
espérons que très prochainement un
mécanisme de contrôle sera validée quel
que soit le sujet des discussions comme
aujourd'hui l'europe et plus
particulièrement les relations entre la
russie et le conseil de l'europe la
situation dans le haut-karabakh s'est
une nouvelle fois retrouvés au coeur des
préoccupations et non sans raison
merci en plein pour toutes ces
précisions